- In 2020, Cardi B sued
YouTube vlogger Tasha K
for defamation, invasion of privacy
and intentional infliction
of emotional distress.
Now, the verdict is in,
and Cardi B is looking like a
moneybag honey bag moneybag.
Love it when we do these on singers.
The jury ordered Tasha
K to pay $1.25 million
for defamation of character,
$1.5 million in punitive damages
and $1.3 million to cover
Cardi B's legal fees.
I guess when Cardi B said,
"Spoil me in Prada, I'm
worth every dollar",
she apparently meant it.
Now we've talked about defamation
many times on this channel,
specifically about how hard
it is for pubic figures
to win a defamation lawsuit.
Well, credit to Cardi B and her lawyers,
they successfully proved that
Tasha K made false claims
and did them with actual malice.
If this verdict holds up,
Cardi B's gonna buy a palace.
♪ Tasha K made claims with actual malice ♪
♪ If this verdict holds up,
Cardi's gonna buy a palace ♪
(cinematic music)
Hey Legal Eagles, it's time to think like,
like YouTube lawyer.
That's kind of fun.
So, just what is the beef
between Cardi B and Tasha K?
Is this the greatest legal fight
between someone who uses their
first name and last initial?
How did Cardi's lawyers convince a jury
that she had been defamed,
and what did Tasha K argue in defense?
Well listen up, because you're
about to get a masterclass
in how Cardi B bossed
up and changed the game.
Okay, so let's talk about the beef
between Cardi B and Tasha K.
YouTuber Latasha Kebe,
also known as Tasha K,
is a popular podcast
host, vlogger and blogger.
She posts interviews and opinion pieces
on her YouTube channel,
Unwind with Tasha K.
She has over a million subscribers
and also hosts a streaming
service called tashaklive.com.
Now, on September 19, 2018,
Tasha published a video
of an interview she conducted
with Starmarie Jones.
Jones claimed that she had
been roommates with Cardi B
during Cardi's stripper days.
Jones told Tasha that Cardi
had prostituted herself
to make a living before
she became a rap superstar.
Jones said she lived with Cardi
and knew for a fact that Cardi got herpes.
But as far back as 2018,
there was evidence that Starmarie Jones
was not who she claimed to be.
Before she went viral by claiming
to be Cardi's ex roommate,
Jones said that she
actually did not know Cardi
but felt jealousy over
Cardi's record deal.
Later, she apparently concocted
a story about knowing Cardi.
Tasha then repeated Jones' claims
on all of her social media channels.
Should Tasha have believed
Starmarie's story?
Well, another YouTuber,
Empressive, says no.
Empressive figured out that
Jones lied way back in 2018.
In her video, she revealed
that Jones admitted
she had never met Cardi,
and points out that
Starmarie is very bitter
that her own music career never took off.
Here, Empressive shows a clip
of Jones meeting with Tasha.
Empressive says that she felt sorry
that Tasha fell for Jones' lies,
but she felt like it was
important to be responsible
about whose stories
vloggers choose to promote.
Nevertheless, over the next three years,
Tasha again repeated the Jones claims
in at least 38 videos about Cardi B.
She also discussed them during
Instagram Live recordings
and on Facebook.
None of those videos portrayed
Cardi B in a positive light,
and of course, because of the
First Amendment, that's okay.
In America, you can express
your own negative opinion
about someone else,
as long as you don't make up
false statements about them.
You can even call them names.
So did Tasha K cross the line
between defamation and opinion?
Well it depends on the details
of the actual statements,
but here's how the beef went down.
Well first, on September 19, 2018,
Tasha published a video of herself
discussing the Jones' video.
It was titled, "Exclusive:
Cardi B's Ex-Friend
"Alleges Cardi B Kept A Huge
Box Filled with Monistat
"and Reveals More."
The video got four million views.
Cardi B's lawyers sent a cease
and desist letter to Tasha,
demanding immediate removal of the video.
Tasha then doubled down on her claims,
publishing a video entitled,
"Actual Proof Cardi B
Knew Her Ex-Roommate,
"Drake, Funky Dineva vs
Tamar, Beyonce Black Majic",
where she stated that everything said
in the September 19th video was true.
This is an important shift in perspective.
Originally, Tasha attributed
Jones as the source
for the assorted allegations
about Cardi's past,
and in terms of news reporting,
you often get more protection
in a defamation context
when you're simply reporting
what someone else has said,
compared to things that
you yourself have said.
However, in the September
19th video, Tasha K said,
"Everything that we said that
Jones said was accurate."
So did this set Tasha on a course
that she found hard to back down from?
Well, on December 18, 2018,
she published a video on YouTube entitled,
"Tasha K Responds to
Cardi B's Defamation Suit
"and Offset's Dad calling
Cardi B Out, and More".
In this video, Tasha alleges
that when she was a stripper,
Cardi B used a beer bottle to,
well you can see what that says.
Then on January 25, 2019,
Tasha tweeted that Cardi B had herpes.
The tweet prompted Cardi to
formally request a retraction
and repudiation of these statements.
Although Tasha temporarily
removed the videos and posts,
by September of 2021,
she had relisted and reposted the videos.
In the meantime, Tasha
continued to repeat allegations
about prostitution and herpes in videos
and Instagram Live sessions.
On April 23, 2019,
Tasha published a video on YouTube called,
"Tasha K Responds to Cardi
B's Mute Black Blogs Agenda,
"Cardi Calls Shade Room
Owner a Water Buffalo".
I don't know what any
of these things mean.
This is not my preferred
videos on YouTube,
but hopefully you can
parse what's going on here.
In other videos and on
Instagram and Facebook posts,
Tasha made these claims again and again,
just like she did with
the other allegations.
She also claimed Cardi was a cheater
who had contracted the HPV virus.
There's more, but by now,
you kinda get the point.
Tasha K did not like Cardi B
and was making lots of serious allegations
about Cardi's life as a stripper.
Now, I think it's important to point out
that yes, Cardi B was a stripper.
She's given candid interviews
about that time in her life
and raps about it.
However, being a stripper isn't
a get out of liability card
for Tasha K, which brings us
to the complaint at issue.
On March 21, 2019, Cardi B sued
Tasha K and Starmarie Jones
in the US District Court
for the Northern District of Georgia.
Although defamation
and invasion of privacy
are state law claims, the case
was filed in federal court
because the plaintiff and defendant
live in different states,
and the amount in
controversy was over $75,000.
This is called diversity jurisdiction.
Now, Jones chose not to
defend herself in the lawsuit,
so a New York Supreme Court judge
granted Cardi's motion
for default judgment.
I'm not gonna go into why
this is in New York Court at the moment,
but as part of that judge's order,
the video was removed
and Jones was prohibited
from talking about the
defamatory statements
about Cardi in the future.
The judge's order explicitly states
that as a matter of law,
the defendant's statements
that plaintiff had engaged
in prostitution and has or had herpes
are held to be defamatory,
as they are untrue
and were made without justification
or proof by defendant.
Now the default judgment against Jones
put Tasha K in a precarious position.
Cardi alleged that Tasha
made the following defamatory statements:
Cardi B was a prostitute,
Cardi B had certain STIs,
Cardi B performed certain sexual acts,
and Cardi B took cocaine and ecstasy.
Now, Tasha published these statements
on her social media sites,
garnering millions of views and likes.
Cardi alleged that they
damaged her reputation
in the industry, with her fans,
and disrupted potential
business relationships.
Now, Tasha K denied that
she had defamed Cardi.
She alleged that all
the statements were true
and that they were not
made with actual malice.
She argued that she had the right
to rely on Jones' original claims.
Now, Cardi B's first and main
claim was for defamation.
We've covered defamation many times,
but you generally prove that
by showing four elements:
A false statement was
made about the plaintiff,
the statement was published
where other people saw or heard it,
the statement harmed the
plaintiff's reputation
and no privilege of defense
existed for the statement,
and Georgia law basically tracks
our basic understanding of defamation.
And of course, you have to
have a certain mental state.
Generally it's negligence
about the falsehood of the statements.
But when you're dealing with
someone like a celebrity,
you have to have actual malice,
which means you knowingly
or recklessly said these false things.
That's the higher standard.
It doesn't have anything to do
with actually not liking a person.
Actual malice is about knowingly
or recklessly repeating
these false statements.
And of course, truth is
a defense to defamation.
In other words, defamatory
statements must be false
to be actionable.
You can say something mean about someone
that hurts their reputation,
as long as what you say is
accurate or it's opinion
or other things that don't rise
to the level of defamation.
And here, there was no question
that the statements were published
and disseminated to third parties,
but the questions of whether
a particular communication
was defamatory
and whether the defendant had
the requisite mental state
were for the jury to decide.
Now here, the mental state
is really interesting,
because usually, you only
have to prove negligence.
But following in a famous
Supreme Court case,
New York Times vs Sullivan,
when you're dealing with a public figure,
you have to prove actual malice.
In the Sullivan case,
the Supreme Court held
that public official
could not recover damages
for defamatory statements
regarding his or her official conduct,
unless it was proven that
the statement was made
with actual malice, which
again, is a legal term
that has nothing to do
with hatred of a person.
It's about the mental state
of knowing that the statements are false.
Later, the Supreme Court
extended the actual malice rule
to apply to criticism of a public figure.
Public figures are people who are,
"intimately involved in the resolution
"of important public questions
or, by reason of their fame,
"shape events in areas of
concern to society at large."
Basically, the Supreme Court thought
that if it was too easy
to prove defamation,
then rich and influential people,
as well as government officials,
could use their power
to chill free speech.
And that could certainly be a
concern in a case like this,
since an extremely famous person
who presumably has lots of money,
sued someone who has
presumably fewer resources.
And this is why Tasha K called out Cardi B
for attempting to silence
her voice as a vlogger.
On the other hand, vloggers like Tasha K
have pretty big platforms
to spread malicious gossip,
and these days, everyone
has access to the Internet,
where these things can be repeated.
So her success in social
media made her a bigger target
than someone who doesn't have
a big social media presence.
Now, this wasn't necessarily an easy case.
The judge in Cardi B's case concluded
that there was a genuine
dispute of material fact,
but whether all of Tasha
K's statements were,
in fact, false and defamatory,
and that it was going to be up to the jury
to decide these questions.
For example, in this case,
Cardi denied ever being a
prostitute or using drugs.
However, Tasha K offered
evidence that during interviews,
Cardi had talked about
engaging in sexual acts
in exchange for money.
In that same video, Cardi B
discusses her use of drugs
and about having to pop pills
sometimes when necessary.
What does it mean to pop pills?
Does this imply that she
popped cocaine and Molly,
or that she took Benadryl and Tylenol?
The jury's job was to
review all the evidence
and decide whether these
statements were false.
So let's talk about the
evidence regarding STIs.
Juries who hear civil cases
review quite a lot of evidence,
and here's a list of the
exhibits admitted to the court
in this particular case.
There are 1021 exhibits.
Now the jury didn't
hear hours of testimony
on each of these exhibits,
but they did have access
to all this material,
which Cardi B alleged proved
the elements of her claims.
And here's Tasha K's list of exhibits.
She offered 125 exhibits
in an attempt to prove
that what she said was true about Cardi B.
And although we aren't privy
to the jury's deliberations,
we do know that Tasha failed to prove
that her comment about Cardi
B having STIs was true.
In discovery, Tasha asked for an order
requiring Cardi to turn
over her medical records.
Cardi had already submitted STI tests,
but did not fight the order.
The judge granted her
request to produce material
under a protective order.
That means that the judge
can see the medical records,
but that they are sealed from public view.
And when you're talking
about medical records,
that makes perfect sense.
And in December, the judge
reviewed Cardi's medical records
and ruled that they did not
show that Cardi had any STIs.
Quote, "The Court has received
and reviewed the records
"and finds that they are
not helpful to Defendant.
"Accordingly, the Court will
file the records under seal.
"At Plaintiff's request only,
"the Court will release
the records to both sides
"to be used at trial.
"Otherwise, the records
shall not be opened
"except with permission
of the District Judge
"or the Court of Appeals."
And then there's evidence
about lying under oath.
Why didn't Tasha K have more
credibility with the jury?
Well, she was caught lying on the stand.
"On cross examination, Tasha K was asked,
"'isn't it a fact that you
testified in your deposition
"'that you are not a journalist?'
"Answer: 'yes'.
"'So when you told your subscribers
"'that you were a
journalist, you were lying?'
"Answer: 'yes'."
And when Tasha told her
viewers that her lawyer friend
had reviewed Cardi's
cease and desist letter
and that it was bogus, she was also lying.
Under cross examination,
she said that the person was
just a friend, not a lawyer.
This, by the way, is called
impeachment of a witness
and it can be incredibly devastating.
She was also asked,
"Isn't it true that you
lied in your deposition
"when you provided a date
"when you put up a video
defaming my client?"
Answer: "I made up a date
"because you were being
combative towards me."
Tasha's husband kind of
threw her under the bus.
Asked, "Is it true your
wife lied when she said
"that there are several
businesses under Kebe Studios?"
Answer: "yes".
Journalist Dennis Byron,
a contributor to TMZ,
live tweeted the trial.
He revealed that Tasha's husband
refuted her testimony four times.
And then, of course, there is the evidence
about actual malice.
Here, the jury must've found
that Tasha K acted with actual malice.
That is that she made
statements with knowledge
that it was false, or
with reckless disregard
of whether it was false or not.
What evidence did the jury have
to show that Tasha shouldn't
have relied on Jones
and the other statements?
Well, Cardi's lawyers had
videos where Tasha conceded
that she repeated things that
she knew weren't really true.
In one of the exhibits, a
phone interview, Tasha states,
"Here's my thing, all of
these strippers are lying",
referring to Jones,
Cardi and a third party.
In that same call, Tasha
concludes that Jones, quote,
"told some truths, she
didn't tell all truths."
One of the most damning pieces
of evidence in this trial
was when the Court played a phone call
between Tasha and
celebrity blogger Lovely T,
who told Tasha that the information
from Starmarie Jones was fake
and she shouldn't repeat the claims.
At one point in the trial,
Tasha conceded that in her deposition,
she said it would be funny to
claim that Cardi B had HPV.
Quote, "Is it a fact that you
testified in your deposition
"that you thought it was
funny to say Cardi B had HPV?"
Answer: "yes".
That definitely does not put Tasha
in a very sympathetic light.
The jury also found in Cardi's favor
on the invasion of privacy
and intentional infliction
of emotional distress claims.
In Georgia,
a claim for intentional
infliction of emotional distress,
or IIED, has four elements:
that there was intentional
or reckless conduct,
which is extreme and outrageous,
which caused emotional distress,
which is severe.
In support of her IIED claim,
Cardi pointed to a video
where Tasha says she had a
personal vendetta against Cardi.
The jury could've found that
Tasha, therefore, had a motive
to defame Cardi's character.
In this case, the jury
was probably satisfied
that Tasha's statements
were extreme and outrageous.
However, it's possible that
this particular verdict
might get overturned because,
"conduct that can be
characterized as merely vulgar,
"tasteless, rude or insulting
"generally should not
support a claim for IIED."
Now, there was also cause of
action for invasion of privacy,
which, ironically, was the
name of Cardi B's debut album.
Georgia has adopted four
forms of invasion of privacy.
The one at issue in this
case is invasion of privacy
through portrayal in a false light.
The elements of that claim
are that the defendant
publicized a matter concerning plaintiff
that places plaintiff in a false light,
the defendant acts in a reckless disregard
as to the truth or falsity
of the publicized matter
and the false light in which
the plaintiff would be placed,
and that the false light in
which the plaintiff was placed
would be highly offensive
to a reasonable person.
And in support of her
invasion of privacy claim,
Cardi B emphasized the many
times that Tasha admitted
that her stories were false
when she published them.
She apparently was quotes as saying,
"You know what's funny, I make
up stories out of thin air.
"Tasha just makes up stories."
She also said, "I knew it was fake.
"I still made that stuff go viral anyway."
So that was probably more than enough
to win on that particular
invasion of privacy claim.
Now, as for the damages
that Cardi B is able to
recover in this case,
the jury awarded Cardi $1
million in general damages
for the reputational
damages she experienced.
In Georgia, actual
damages explicitly include
impairment of reputation and
standing in the community.
Cardi's complaint alleged that
some of Tasha's statements
were defamation per quod, and
others were defamation per se.
Defamation per se are
statements which are considered
to be so harmful on their face
that the plaintiff doesn't
need to prove special damages.
Tasha accused Cardi of having
STIs, working as a prostitute,
committing lewd acts with a beer bottle,
and all of these statements likely qualify
as defamation per se, so Cardi
didn't have to prove damages
to win on liability.
And many of Cardi's trial
exhibits presented proof
that she incurred medical expenses
because of emotional distress.
Cardi B testified that
she considered suicide,
experienced anxiety, weight
loss, depression and migraines.
She also said it impacted her relationship
with her husband, Offset.
Now, Tasha accused Cardi of having herpes,
pointing to a photograph
of a mark on her lip.
People started to comment about it
on Cardi's social media posts,
and when Cardi B posted a photo
of her kissing her daughter,
people commented that she was
going to give her kid herpes.
Cardi B said it had a serious
impact on her mental health
and she sought treatment with a therapist
because of the ordeal.
The therapist, Dr Sherry Blake,
said that during the two
years she treated Cardi,
her mental health deteriorated
because Tasha would not stop badgering her
with these claims.
On top of that, Cardi
was awarded $1.5 million
in punitive damages.
After the jury found Tasha
liable for defamation,
the lawyers offered evidence
regarding punitive damages
and attorney's fees and costs.
Each side had 20 minutes
to present evidence,
but Tasha's lawyers, who are
criminal defense lawyers,
only took 90 seconds.
The jury awarded Cardi an
additional $2.8 million
in punitive damages and attorney's fees.
Georgia allows punitive
damages in defamation cases
under certain circumstances.
Punitive damages are given solely
to punish or penalize
or deter a defendant,
and to prove those damages,
the plaintiff must show
that the defendant's actions
showed willful misconduct,
malice, fraud, wantedness or oppression.
If the defendant
demonstrated total disregard
for the consequences of her actions,
a jury can impose punitive
damages to punish that defendant.
And a plaintiff must prove this
by clear and convincing evidence,
which is higher than the
preponderance standard
that you're usually dealing
with in a civil case,
though there is a $250,000 cap
on punitive damages in Georgia,
unless the plaintiff can prove
specific intent to cause harm.
The jury deliberated for two hours
before deciding that Cardi B had proved
that Tasha intended to cause harm.
Now, there's also some really interesting
inside baseball here involving
Tasha K and her lawyers.
Cardi B filed suit against Tasha K,
and Tasha K also filed
counterclaims for assault and IIED.
So effectively, within the
same case, she sued Cardi B.
She asserted that Cardi
deliberately got her fans riled up
by falsely claiming
that Tasha was stalking
Cardi and her friends and
making up fake stories.
She also said that Cardi called her names,
like dumb ass bitch and hoe.
Tasha also said that when Cardi threatened
to bankrupt Tasha, by stating
quote, and I'm quoting here,
"All right then bitch,
"I'm gonna take all your fucking bread",
she meant that she was
going to get violent.
Tasha said Cardi's fans
then made verbal threats,
and she was forced to move several times
because of the fans.
The judge dismissed these counterclaims
because Tasha couldn't
prove that Cardi B herself
had threatened Tasha
or made her believe that
she was going to harm her.
And although fans made lots of threats,
there was no evidence
that Cardi communicated
with any of these people,
let alone that she asked them
to take action against Tasha.
And the IIED counterclaim
failed for the same reasons.
Even if Tasha suffered emotional distress
because Cardi's fans behaved
in an extreme and outrageous manner,
Tasha couldn't prove
causation from Cardi B.
Since there wasn't any evidence
that Cardi committed these acts,
that she directed others to
harass and intimidate Tasha,
the claim was dismissed before trial.
And many people, including Tasha,
had criticism for Tasha's lawyers.
Many news outlets concluded
that Tasha's lawyer,
Olga Izmaylova, was not prepared for trial
and had no experience
at defamation claims.
Izmaylova is primarily a
criminal defense lawyer.
Her cross examination of
Cardi took barely an hour,
the judge told her to
go back to law school
and curiously, Tasha reviewed Izmaylova
back in June of 2021,
shortly after the Court
dismissed her counterclaims.
According to the website AVVO,
which is a very mainstream
place to rate lawyers,
Tasha gave her lawyer one star
out of five, saying, quote,
"Will not use this attorney again",
one star, posted by
Latasha Kebe, June 5, 2021.
"Very disappointed with this attorney.
"I hired her to represent
me in a defamation case,
"but I will have to seek another attorney.
"Olga has, on several occasions,
"shown up to Court unprepared
"and unfamiliar with
the facts of the case.
"She advised me to file a
counter suit, which I did,
"but it is clear now that
that was not the best move.
"After advising me to counter sue,
"she then doubled back
"and dropped several
counts on the counter suit.
"So why did she advise me to
file it in the first place?
"At the last hearing, she was stuttering
"and tripping over her words,
and it was embarrassing.
"An attorney is supposed
to exude confidence
"in their client,
"but it's like she is not
fighting to win the case.
"She is just going through the motions
"and showing up to court.
"After paying her thousands of dollars
"over the past three years
this case has been dragging on,
"I'm no better off.
"I'm counting my losses and moving on.
"I will not be using this attorney again."
So there's no guarantee that Tasha K
actually was the one that wrote this
and posted this to AVVO, but
it sounds pretty genuine.
But it does raise the question,
why would she continue with
this lawyer through trial
if she had these criticisms?
But passing judgment on Tasha's lawyer
is beyond the scope of this video,
and I'll say that
sometimes lawyers are bad
and sometimes lawyers just have to deal
with the client that they have,
not the client that they wish they had.
But now, the judge is probably
going to order Tasha K
to take down the offending YouTube videos,
and it's possible that YouTube
might just delete her channel
for breaking the law.
So since she'll probably
have to start over,
she could really benefit
from MKBHD's class,
"YouTube Success: Script,
Shoot and Edit with MKBHD"
on today's sponsor, Skillshare.
If she takes that class, she'll
learn how to plan a video
that's true to her but
also widely appealing
and also just, you know, true,
shoot compelling content
with whatever gear she has,
edit the footage to grab attention
and grow her channel strategically
while still having fun
and presumably not breaking the law,
because Skillshare has
classes on almost everything,
from video to music to
business and entrepreneurship.
Skillshare, as you know, is
one of the world's largest
online learning communities,
with tens of thousands
of classes on everything,
and it's the best place to
get a start on the Internet.
Or, if you're Tasha K, get a new start.
And if you'd like to try out Skillshare,
the first 1000 Legal Eagles
to use my link in the description
will get a free trial
of Skillshare Premium.
And for a limited time, that
trial is for an entire month,
not the normal 14 days.
So, just click on the link
that's on screen right now
or the one that's in the description
to get a free trial of Skillshare Premium.
Plus, clicking on that link
really helps out this channel.
And while you're there,
click on this other link
with all of my other Real Law Reviews,
so click on this link where
I'll see you in court.